[Music]
Singer r.kelly is speaking out for the
first time since being arrested and
charged on ten counts of felony
aggravated sexual abuse of young girls
he's been accused of everything from
child pornography to running a sex cult
of the past 25 years but Kelly maintains
his innocence and that he's the real
victim
joining me now exclusively as an old
friend Drew Pinsky an addiction
specialist and doctor to the Stars dr.
drew what what do you make of that
interview
he's obviously extremely emotional
explosive and I was worried about Gayle
King for a moment there yeah I'm you
know it's good to see you Laurel by the
way and I got to tell you this is a lot
of celebrities have been scrutinized
lately and this is the first time I've
been frightened for him for somebody I'm
fearful this guy could hurt himself I
mean he really his backing is against
the wall he's financially in very
serious trouble he couldn't afford his
bail he couldn't afford afford child
support so today he was arrested on this
he can't have access to his children
he's being accused of very serious
crimes he is in big trouble and he is in
desperate straits so I'm actually
worried about this guy well does it seem
to some extent I can you tell and it's
difficult it it almost seems like it's
like an ongoing reality show drama the
the standing up you know hitting your
chest I mean it seems it seems
choreographed a little bit I mean if I
had to I'm not an expert you are but
that's just a layman's well what you're
looking at is you're thinking to
yourself I think you don't protest too
much right it's I can tell too much it's
excessive doesn't mean he did it we just
don't know we can't know for sure
I mean look we're looking at a lot
a lot of celebrities life with a new
lens I feel like we've all woken up from
the slumber of the 70s when anything
goes I mean look at some of the lyrics
from music from that era they're talking
about 14 year olds half the time you
know all of a sudden we've begun to
scrutinize these people that we have
idolized merely because of their music
or their appearance on television or
movies and it is it has been seductive
and it is ridiculous we're looking at
things very realistically now go ahead
yeah he he talked about what the parents
of the girls the alleged victims their
role in all of this let's watch as real
Clary what can you tell what is your
relationship with her right now I'm
seeing her you were seeing good she's 21
I'm seeing her she's 21 yeah but did you
start seeing her at 17 solutely not did
you have sex with her when she was 70
absolutely not
absolutely not although her parents
wanted me to again dr. drew I mean could
that happen I guess it could have
parents well I you must have seen the
Michael you must have seen the Michael
Jackson leaving Neverland documentary
where whether or not those allegations
are true or not you see how for somebody
to be seduced to seduce a young person
you have to seduce the entire family and
fame we have such we elevate people with
Fame to such a degree we are as easily
seduced by it and it's possible I don't
know we just don't know what has
actually gone on one of the things he
did say a couple things kid jumped out
at me about his interview that I thought
we're very interesting one is he
compartmentalized a lot he talked about
our Kelley vs. Robert and my
understanding is he had some very
serious trauma himself and that's how
people are traumatized think they
compartmentalize the self and their
emotions and that sometimes how they
carry out things that are not good the
this compartmentalized piece of
themselves is disavowed that's not
really me I'm really Robert and they can
do some awful stuff and be a good person
at the same time that's one thing the
judge jumped out of me in this
particular interview there seemed to be
a good deal of compartmentalization the
other thing is something that I see
celebrities do all the time which is the
name that you use out in the world
you know the r.kelly again versus robert
is not just compartmentalization this
the thing you know of as the celebrity
they distance themselves from as though
well that's just a cartoon character so
when people criticize that celebrity
r.kelly it really doesn't get through to
me Robert dr. drew I also want to get
your thoughts on another big star you
mentioned the issue with Michael Jackson
and HBO HBO is out with this new
documentary about about MJ called
leaving Neverland and a details years a
superstar allegedly abused two young
boys let's watch there's no thoughts of
this is wrong or anything like that told
me if they ever found out what we were
doing he and I would go to jail for the
rest of our lives
dr. drew why is this coming out now this
I mean he he did it was on it was in
trial you know he he won the settlements
he's been he's dead
what what's going on here well we don't
know what these guys we don't know what
the allegations are true or not but I
will tell you the documentary shows
again the grooming process precisely at
how it happens if you saw Oprah's
interview after after the leaving never
Neverland second part she excuse me she
talks about that how this is really
important thing for people to understand
that it's something that people are
drawn into it's not painful and it's not
an attack
it's a grooming process and by the same
token because they love that as
celebrity they loved Michael Jackson
they wanted to protect him they had all
these ambivalent feelings that when they
really woke up to what he had been doing
to them there was a flood of emotions
and then there was a desire to talk
about it so the theory here if these
allegations are true is they finally got
enough distance and in fact from both
men's case it was the fact that they had
children that they started to look at
the child to go oh my god somebody did
something to me when I was young this is
unbelievable and that's where the
emotional flood broke through and
somebody chose to tell the story whether
it's true or not yeah again but he's
obviously not around to defend himself
none of us knows if it's true or false
but that's I
the difficulty I just think I got I just
think we're waking up from a slumber I
really do I really believe that we are
waking up from a slumber from the 70s
I've been saying this the all the years
Oh is on lovely I kept saying there is
horrible things going on and we are
accepting it and we look at the thing
when you look at the pictures of Michael
Jackson and now running around with the
kids you go oh my god how do we we all
were groomed into sort of accepting that
and they have been through a period of
history where a lot of things were
acceptable that we're not acceptable I
disagree I think there's a lot of stuff
that is pushing the envelope in family
our TV that's all out the window may not
agree stuff but I think there's I think
I think they envelope this push maybe no
you enjoy the award show it's the way
you work with a little bit I don't
disagree with you at all but there's
stuff we are waking up to as though
we've been in some kind of weird summer
just look at the lyrics of songs to the
seventies some time and think about what
some of these rock stars were doing with
young children and people were like over
there rock stars what he's supposed to
do well yeah waking up well Michael
Jackson actually responded to some of
these allegations in an interview on 60
minutes back in 2009 with Edie Bradley
let's watch if I would hurt a child I
would slit my wrists I would never hurt
a child do you still think that it's
acceptable to share your bed with
children of course of course why not he
went on to say as long as this you know
platonic and no by the way
no no nothing okay about it I don't care
who the 30 year old man is no I don't
care who he is I don't care if half his
Loeb wonder what half of his brain
tissue is gone I no no no that is not
okay
listen if you really watch the
documentary he the kids talk about how
they would go to toy stores and load
baskets full of toys that went out you
would not let that happen as a parent
that's not your your job is to teach
kids how to get effectively into the
world and guess what the world can be a
very frustrating place you don't get
what you want all the time just that
very just going to the toy stores help
me jump again are the parents that's the
same great to see you it's great all
right thank you I appreciate it